he came over and he asked
for her hand in marriage he said
he went to the your dad's grave and
asked your dad i know
and i just lost it yeah you might want
to grab the tissues because turns out
travis barker went to kourtney
kardashian's late dad's grave to ask for
her hand in marriage before he popped
the question beautiful amazing the 46
year old blink 182 drummer asked the 43
year old reality star to marry him on
the beach in montecito california back
in october on their one year anniversary
and now thanks to the famous family's
new hulu series fans get to see the days
that led up to the big moment you have a
real insight into what the girls are
doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
before you would see little snippets of
something and now i think the episodes
are um you know fuller of content that
shows the whole story
well part of that story is kris jenner
telling court sister kim that trav not
only asked her for permission to marry
the pooch founder he also asked their
late dad robert kardashian too
came over and he asked
for her hand in marriage and i was like
literally i want to cry now except for
i'm just doing my makeup
well don't cry it was so sweet and so
tender
and then he said don't cry make up mom
you're getting mario don't start crying
too i know but i just that part that he
asked her is so respected maybe he said
he went to the your dad's grave and
asked your dad i know
and i just lost it
yeah and the whole thing had the 41 year
old skims founder who was prepping for
her hosting gig on saturday night live
totally in her feelings too okay guys i
have to work like can you do why are you
doing this to me
like i really have to work i can't ruin
my makeup it's not happy happy
i know your dad is here to see it
i can hardly believe that it's the first
time that she's getting married look
cute
it's really crazy
that she hasn't been married before
[Laughter]
nice yep
yep and while we'll just have to wait
until next week to see how the whole
proposal goes down we do know court says
yes
i love you
in fact the two said i do in an
unofficial las vegas ceremony earlier
this month you did a practice run on the
wedding congratulations thank you so
thank you when is the real wedding we
don't know yet we're just you know
living our best lives
and thanks to mama jenner fans get a
sneak peek at what the musician says to
court while on bended knee a year ago
today i fell in love with you
one night with you was all it took
you've been one of my best friends for
years oh
i've admired you
and adored you for so long you're the
love of my life
courtney
i want to spend the rest
[Music]
of it with you
will you marry me okay but seriously
where are the tissues people i mean it's
a beautiful thing
as for quartz x scott disick he was in
new york to support kim on snl and
reveals that while the beauty mogul
asked him to appear in one skit he
declined after running the joke by court
i talked to courtney about it
basically like i say to her
you know the reason i date young girls
is because i'm trying to add them all up
so they're your age of course ever since
court and scott split in 2015 he's been
linked to several women in their early
20s like sofia richie and lisa renna and
harry hamlin's daughter amelia gray
hamlin and now scott is dating 27 year
old model rebecca donaldson who he
actually brought to the premiere of the
new show if me and courtney were married
sure i'd make fun of her on tv
but not like separate yeah like it's
just not in good taste you have to
follow your gut and if that that was my
gut and i called her i talked to her
back
and then i came to the conclusion i was
like then tone and
initially i just wanted to come and
support kim and watch and that was it
tim is so happy you're here
so i'm good with that
[Music]